un enjeu politique pour ces élections
départementales pour cela les partis
n'ont pas ménagé leur peine à commencé
par l'UMP qui dès le mois de décemre
avait annoncé son union avec l'UDI pour
des binôes en commun pour le parti de
Nicolas Sarkozi une ambition réaliser le
grand schlem dans le département que les
21 cantons soient gagnés par la droite
nous avons réussi à faire une très belle
unité de la droite du Centre jusqu'au
modemme de toutes les sensibilités de la
droite qui sont réunis aujourd'hui pour
gagner des cantons qui sont jusqu'à
présent réputés ingagnables je pense à
trappe je pense à Guill encours nous
sommes le parti du projet et j'invite
tous les électeurs à ne pas voter pour
les autres partis qui n'ont soit pas de
projet soit qui font campagne sur le
rejet pour le Parti socialiste
l'objectif conserver des cantons
aujourd'hui plaisir MPa trappe
montinuille en cours sont détenus par
des élus de la gauche ils sont neuf
assiéger au conseil général sur 39 élus
on souhaite garder le maximum de canton
que l'on détient et on n a pas énorme
dans le département c'est aussi la
survie du débat démocratique dans le
département qui est en jeu l'ambition
c'est déjà de porter nos valeurs c'est
qu'on a pas d'inhibition on porte des
valeurs qui sont fortes qui sont fait de
tolérance qui s'appuie sur la dévise
républicaine et dans la période c'est
d'actualité la gauche qui n'a pas réussi
à faire l'union sur tous les cantons
Europe Écologie Les ver s'associant dans
certains cas avec le Front de gauche on
souhaite le rassemblement le plus large
possible de la gauche mais sur des
contenus qui sont clairement an
austérité en rupture avec les politiques
qui sont menées aujourd'hui par pas
aller vers le Parti socialiste que de
fait ça revient à ça même si compris on
renonce pas avoir des socialistes qui
nous rejoignent effectivement et
particulièrement sur 5 qutin ça se
décline plutôt sur des rassemblements
avec EUR Écologie Les Verts qui se situe
eux vraiment dans cette rupture
vis-à-vis de de l'austérité alors ce qui
est important pour les électeurs c'est
qu'il se retrouvent dans les programmes
qu'on propose et donc nous on a un
programme qui est différent de celui du
Parti socialiste donc ça nous paraît
logique de le présenter de le proposer
au voix ce qui est très important
important pour nous c'est de d'arriver à
ne pas avoir un département des ivelines
qui soit 100 % à droite ou au Front
National et pour se faire la seule façon
c'est de remobiliser les électeurs de
gauche qui ne vont plus voter
l'abstention les partis la craignent
tout comme le vote du Front national
dans les ivelines le parti de Marine Le
Pen présente un binôme de candidats dans
chacun des cantons c'est une première et
le président départemental ne cache pas
ses ambitions nous voulons gagner le
département nous sommes scandalisés par
la manière dont ce de de Don ce
département est dirigé il se passe des
choses on est le premier parti de France
ça bouge sans arrêt on sent que les les
dig se rompent petit à petit à force de
nous traiter d'antirépublicain les gens
n'y croient plus il y a bien longtemps
autre parti présent pour ces élections
debout la France le parti de Nicolas du
pontaignan présente des candidats dans 8
des 21 canton le message principal c'est
de demander au français reprenez
courages reprenez confiances on peut
faire de la politique intelligemment
dans l'intérêt des Français hors des des
autres partis qui depuis 40 ans vous
baladent et c'est parce que des partis
vous ont mis en colère qu'après on vote
pour les extrêmes ce qui jamais une
solution et qu'il y a d'autres gens qui
sont des patriotes qui sont convaincus
qui peuvent les défendre le premier tour
des élections départementales a lieu le
22 mars la campagne officielle vient de
démarrer ce lundi